the streets is talking that dude with
the hoodie still out there I can't
ignore him the Clallam don't eat me who
cage is not a guy inside of a hero he
has powers he didn't ask for the woman
he fell in love with his dead and he was
put in prison before a crime even commit
guess I can't trust nobody around here
kena Jessica Jones Africa Jessica Jones
he goes uptown he just want to be left
alone
I mean he was a target on your back
Harlan is where he's hiding out he ends
up sweeping up here in a barbershop but
he finds the cottonmouth basically
running Harlan cut no coin Elle
cottonmouth Stokes owns his nightclub
Harlan's paradise but that's really a
front because he's actually a gunrunner
everybody wants to be the king cage
didn't want to get involved I I'm afraid
know how amazing he's just trying to
figure things out you should be out
there helping people reaper used to say
the same thing she was right
you just can't stand idly by but things
happen you want Harlem
I don't want Harlem I just want you to
stop messing with it you see it needs
and you decide that it's your
responsibility to address it that's the
hero's journey
I guess you guys haven't heard about it
here there are no capes this is some
whooping ass it's about who he is and
and what he stands for
you know how the wind feels right before
a big thunderstorm Harlow's the same
trouble smells a certain way that's a
really different vibe a really different
hero you knock down a few doors in the
projects now you are on zero I'm just
getting started
and you want to go to war now take you
to war you might be bulletproof
the Harlem eight